[Music]
and got caught news
this is wounded by Gracie bill a woman
called her boyfriend cheating when the
physical activity reading spike on his
Fitbit because you need to count his
calories and [ __ ] he left it on though I
wanna say how she found out like I got
to get all the way nude if I'm like you
can't only thing that might be on his
socks
maybe sigh if it's cold yeah what not it
money for tracks it you go over the back
like you're barefoot on the carpet with
slips but the soggy now cuz if you think
I'm like I so like barefoot on would
list it right yeah but would um on sock
with slide barefoot on carpet because
it's like cloth on it or night able to
slip but like sometimes like do some
workouts in my bedroom and it's carpet
yeah take my socks off because I keep
sliding really yeah it works the words
are you wearing microfiber socks you got
velcro soccerway
is it a shag carpet one another like the
tight combat carpet is it like this no
it's not like this talk see ya thank you
okay so yeah that is microfiber socks my
carpet is like one of these cyber karpas
it would slide not as much anyway so all
right Dori here James later
no none of you watch anything she's a
NFL reporter yeah she the NFL Court she
got cheated on D yep I know shoes so
they were talking about like the
conversation was about the peloton bike
so someone tweeted out like oh if I if I
got this for my wife like she wouldn't
get angry or whatever so then she ends
up quote tweeting that first of all this
is Jen or Jane
when I say Jenna James well what's her
name janitor Jane this is what she looks
like this is what she tweeted she wrote
an ex-boyfriend once got me a Fitbit for
Christmas I loved it we synced up
motivated each other
hated until he was unaccounted for at 4
a.m. and his physical activity levels
were spiking on the app which the story
wasn't realized she was like damn two
minute bursts he's [ __ ] I was thinking
like what if he was just masturbating
like he could've just been rub one out a
story you have to be your story right Oh
what if he had a nightmare he was like
yeah that's what a lot of people have
been writing in the replies like he
could have just been jerking it off but
with the Fitbit on how many calories of
my [ __ ] burner makes more sense to
have it on jerking off than it is yeah
yeah people were responding they were
like well the real question is why were
you up at 4:00 a.m. so you can see his
physical activity and then she said that
she was at his house calling the cops
because she was there to surprise him
for his birthday but she wasn't home so
that's why she was calling the cops but
then that's when the activity went up
she was like oh my god never mind he's
like she ruined his surprise why was she
surprised him at 4:00 o'clock in the
morning because people are usually home
at that time so maybe she had already
been there throughout the night to be
sleeping exactly but the surprise home
the only way you can surprise them is
well I guess 4 o'clock is booty call
time so like that would be enough sounds
like one trying to smash we are the
problems but you like to have sex yeah
but like we get started we get started
before 4:00 yes absolutely 35 minutes if
the smashing a started before 9:00 in
English out oh I'm in the bed before
1:30 I'm um no meaning like he's
knocking out physical activity going on
you're responsible no my parameters of
my prime time that's cuz you're working
Friday 8 a.m. to 2 very latest 11:30
p.m. is my prime time now yeah good
productive our integrity is gonna be
jeopardized because I'm
I know you're like I don't perform like
this huh what happened to you not like
oh that's I don't like it I still fight
it like I will fuse to go to see I will
I won't
consciously plan to go to sleep I will
fall asleep watching TV or follow see
writing jokes or follow see recording
are looking for videos to screen I fall
asleep I get hit twice see you're
working that's why the older you get
you're working hard I mean I was working
out I squeeze my ass cheeks together to
come faster do your ass cheeks have
freckles to depend on what day it is we
our fathers everywhere don't squeeze I
asked you to come faster if you ever
trust harder yeah I know if anything
yeah I will see over here with me there
to the sky you know if you like the
harder you try the harder it is to
actually know maybe this is cuz I don't
know how to relax like I never know what
to do with my hands but then when you
least want a nut that's when it comes
out but then yeah yeah very psychology
but like if you don't like you too
relaxing looking at the ceiling she
don't look up she like training he was
looking at me like I like the title
Madonna sleep what's better falling
asleep or looking at the ceiling well
fall asleep that was purple I told
outside he like I'm awake you up you're
wrong about there she got mad knows cuz
he got over I definitely was saw it she
slapped me on my stomach like you gonna
fall asleep I was like I told y'all fall
asleep sure that it would be her fault
then yeah she took the challenge and she
failed
that's not your fault she's not an
American ninja yeah he fell on the first
obstacle
it's not my father
I'm sorry Big Ben anyway yeah we're
talking about this Fitbit and so people
are commenting as well they were saying
like I love how his gift ended up riding
him out because he was still wearing it
yeah but yeah and then people are like
why the [ __ ] is he wearing a Fitbit
[ __ ] you are supposed to wear all day
even during your sleep is it because it
tracks your sleep
mm how restless you are and all that so
how does it work it just it's just like
gives you data on like when your
weigh-ins and your calories and then how
much movement and steps that you take
throughout the day estimate that based
off of the movement and your heart rate
yeah I had one that I worked like a
month but it's not very accurate because
I have one and it was supposed to Allah
who will do it just so they can get
their 10,000 steps a day I had that one
and then every day by like 1 or 2 p.m.
it ordered already said that already
accomplished 10,000 steps but then when
I got another watch called the Garmin
the same time we'll say 7,000 I don't
know I don't think I'm having 10,000
steps got only one maybe it's like extra
sensitive where like any movement it
counts it as a stuff
yeah I think I think you'll so you could
just go like this all day yeah
definitely a phone so if you keep your
phone in your pocket
it account your steps with the swinging
of the leg too but nothing is like you
gotta you need to get an ankle bracelet
that's the only way to really do it a
break is what if you're just spigot II
though because even when I'm sitting I'm
like tap dancing yeah
so is it steps does it count as a step I
think it like some of them is the actual
swing emotion like with the Fitbit like
it's this actual motion so like if you
were walking and you like your head to
your hands to your pocket
I don't even think it would count that
[ __ ] right so like it's an actual swing
of motion so the ankle might be more
accurate than anything but then it's not
gonna be a lot of guys like yeah I got
my ankle bracelet Fitbit on I'm out here
my best slide a lot of guys yeah but
that's not that's not by choice
[Laughter]
do what they do to get it yeah but once
you got it you won't have a choice of
wedding [ __ ] put the bracelet on
put the bracelet on I won't feel my
ankle weights I used to wear those when
I was playing basketball in elementary
in my dad's like yeah just keep these on
and then you know your job higher yeah
exactly
and then like later he found out like oh
you know you're too young to be putting
those on like development so like he's
like yeah you're not actually posed to
like be working out or like do anything
weightlifting oh okay
yeah I remember the shoe they had like
with the pumpers it was it was like a
little circle but the shoe was like on a
circle or the jumps on the balls of your
feet all the time it's like for boxing -
yeah it really was like a circle and
then like a little thing to hold in the
middle and then a shoe on top of it it's
almost like a reverse high-heeled yeah
like a cert like a real big circle like
where is this you're the top of your
foot yeah the circles like right around
here so it's like built into the shoe so
it makes you like like stay on the ball
of your feet so like like for boxing or
like a basketball even with tennis flag
with tennis we have to keep moving they
call it happy feet so you always have to
like be like this so you never like
taking off from that man
the theory is supposed to make you like
jump higher well we're supposed to be on
not our heels but the balls of our feet
when we're running - holy yeah but with
shoes and the way that we walk we go
like this like you first huh but we're
supposed to be like this because when
you listen you pose me on the balls of
your feet right like what are you doing
squats you pause beyond this part all
right I'm supposed to be on the mid-foot
really something like here not here
somebody's trying to send told me like I
need to be right here with it no I
should be under mid-foot
Lilly yeah your toes to make contact
with the ground they should feel
pressure with the toes on the ground
they come together because I'm cause
some people
yeah we need to figure this out the
balls our feet are up here I thought
this was the body or foot back here this
is the ball above this yes all right
here yeah hello art yeah this part
should be you should feel pressure here
but nobody touches the arch unless you
got a flat foot toes out so that you can
crank the floor and drive your knees out
that's the proper way I gotta learn it
again personal trainers dad you invited
me I would have known as months ago you
should go work out with them and you're
gonna be like actually I don't want to
be a mugger what I got to lose my life
not hard the day of its two three days
after when you're like [ __ ] Bart man no
I'll take the BCAAs I'll be good I take
small fools let me put it in my water I
just said you actually might like it
because of the way you don't like to be
tired and you let you just go go go yeah
yeah it might fit with your personality
more no I'm ready I got my protein shake
a line of coke I'm ready to go
[Music]